>>> BREAKING NEWS, THE HOUSE HAS
ADJOURNED TODAY AFTER A WILD
PROCESS WHERE REPUBLICAN LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY FAILED TO SECURE
ENOUGH VOTES THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES THIS HAS NOT HAPPENED
SINCE 1923.
LET'S BRING IN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS MAN PETE SESSIONS OF
TEXAS.
HE VOTED FOR McCARTHY ON ALL
THREE BALLOTS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU ARE IN A
PLACE WHERE YOU'RE STARTING TO
THINK THERE SHOULD BE A
DIFFERENT CANDIDATE, NOT JIM
JORDAN, NOT KEVIN McCARTHY,
SOMEBODY THAT THE ENTIRE OR AT
LEAST 218 OF YOU CAN COALESCE
AROUND.
>> THAT'S A CONVERSATION THAT'S
TAKING PLACE ABOUT HOW DO WE GET
OUT OF THE MESS?
I THINK HOW DO WE GET OUT OF
THIS IS A QUESTION THAT COMES
ABOUT AS A RESULT OF A DESIRE
THAT THE 20 PEOPLE, 19, 20
PEOPLE HAVE WHO ARE SOLID IN
THEIR BELIEF THAT THEY WOULD
WANT SOMETHING THAT THEY COULD
COUNT ON, SOMETHING THAT THEY
CANNOT JUST TAKE BACK HOME BUT
KNOW THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL HAVE A SOLID UNDERSTANDING
THEY WILL ACHIEVE THE THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO OUR PARTY
BUT ALSO THESE 19 PEOPLE.
SO I THINK THAT IS WHY WE'RE IN
ADJOURNMENT.
I THINK THAT IS THE CONVERSATION
THAT WILL TAKE PLACE TONIGHT AND
THEN IT'S TO BE SEEN WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> ALLIES OF GOP LEADER McCARTHY
SAY HE HAS DONE ALMOST
EVERYTHING HE COULD GIVE THE
REBELS, CHANGING THE RULES,
MAKING IT EASIER TO GET RID OF
THE SPEAKER WITH A MOTION TO
VACATE ON THE FLOOR, MAKING IT
EASIER TO BRING BILLS TO THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE FOR
AMENDMENTS AND THE LIKE.
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD MAYBE FORMER
CONGRESSMAN MULVANEY SAY IT'S
NOT UP TO KEVIN McCARTHY OR ANY
SPEAKER TO PROMISE PEOPLE THEY
WILL BE ON CERTAIN COMMITTEES.
THAT'S FOR THE ENTIRE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS TO VOTE ON AND SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS ARE WHY WON'T
THESE REBELS TAKE YES FOR AN
ANSWER?
BUT IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THAT'S
WHAT YOU THINK.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU THINK THEY
NEED MORE AND THEY SHOULD GET
MORE.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
PEELING BACK THE ONION, YOU SEE
THERE IS MUCH MORE BEHIND THAT
AND THE PROBLEM IS AGREEMENT
WHAT THE AGENDA WILL BE.
A QUESTION ABOUT AS A TEXAN, WE
ARE CONCERNED.
I VOTED FOR KEVIN, WOULD BE FOR
KEVIN.
WE NEED A SPEAKER.
WE NEED TO GET ON WITH THE
MAJORITY BUT I THINK THAT THERE
ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT THESE 19
PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT THE RESOLVE
ABOUT CUTTING A DEAL THAT WOULD
BE LESS THAN GETTING WHAT THEY
WANT AND NEED, AND I THINK IT'S
RESOLVE IS WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO.
I THINK THAT'S THEIR STICKING
POINT.
>> I GUESS ONE OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS LET'S SAY
WE'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF TIMES
FROM CHIP ROY EARLIER BUT ALSO
ON THE FLOOR FROM JIM JORDAN AND
STEVE SCALISE ABOUT ISSUES
IMPORTANT.
TWO CONSECUTIVES, TWO
REPUBLICANS, TWO TEXANS, LET'S
SAY BORDER SECURITY WHICH IS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AND LET'S
SAY THE FENTANYL PROBLEM GOING
ON IN THIS COUNTRY, WHICH IS
HORRIFIC.
WHATEVER, WHOEVER IS SPEAKING OF
THE HOUSE AND I DON'T KNOW -- I
CAN'T IMAGINE THAT A SPEAKER JIM
JORDAN OR A SPEAKER STEVE
SCALISE WOULD BE DIFFERENT BUT
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER IS NAMED
CHUCK SCHUMER, NOT MITCH
McCONNELL AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS NAMED JOE
BIDEN AND NOT DONALD TRUMP.
SO WHOEVER THE SPEAKER IS
COMPROMISES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BE MADE,
>> JAKE.
YOU'RE A SAVVY INSIDER.
ARTICLE 1, SECTION 7 COMES INTO
PLAY WITH A NEW FISCAL YEAR THAT
IS NOT UNTIL OCTOBER.
SO THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN THEN
WOULD BE WHERE WE WOULD
NEGOTIATE THAT.
BUT THERE'S MUCH TO BE DONE
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN.
I GUARANTEE YOU IT IS HARDBALL
AND IT'S HARDBALL DIRECTLY AT
THIS PRESIDENT AND DIRECTLY AT
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK THAT COOLER HEADS CAN
PREVAIL ABOUT HOW WE PEEL BACK
THAT ONION.
AND THERE WOULD BE ROOM TO
UNDERSTAND, IF WE COULD GET A
SOLID AGREEMENT ON A BORDER, WE
COULD CERTAINLY DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS FENTANYL ISSUE.
WE COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT ALL
THE CITIES, HUNDREDS OF CITIES
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE HAVING
PROBLEMS DIRECTLY BECAUSE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED FOR
THE COUNTRY, TOO.
I THINK THERE IS ROOM.
I THINK THERE'S ROOM.
IT WILL REQUIRE SOMEONE THAT
WANTS TO GO AND ACTUALLY PLAY
HARDBALL.
THAT'S WHAT THESE 19 ARE DOING.
>> AM I READING YOU CORRECTLY?
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOUR MIND IS OPEN
FOR HOW YOU'LL VOTE ON THE
FOURTH BALLOT?
>> ONCE AGAIN, JIM JORDAN VOTED
FOR KEVIN McCARTHY.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE JIM JORDAN TO
SEE SOME BIT OF LIGHT ABOUT WHAT
HE SEES A PATHWAY IS OF WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT.
KEVIN McCARTHY VOTED FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY.
JIM IS VOTING FOR KEVIN.
SO I THINK UNTIL PEOPLE COME
WITH A CLEAR SENSE OF WHAT IS IT
GOING THE TAKE FOR US TO GET TO
218, WE'RE GOING TO BE IN THIS
SORT OF ROUND-ROBIN.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK, IS COOLER